hey everyone I just wanted to share this
idea I had and it proved useful to me in
the past so whenever you're playing in
the high rated moment and you know you
feel you're at a disadvantage
for this or that reason you should
always go online and look for some of
the games that she lost and you will
find games that she walked and she
played bad moves right from the
beginning and it will give you some
confidence you'll be able to play
without being afraid to play against
high rated opponent I'm talking about
the maybe towards 300 rating points
higher rated opponent and actually this
one time I had to prepare for two games
and I didn't have time to prepare for
both of them so I just prefer for one
and I want the one game I prepared for
and the game I didn't prepare for I just
found the one game that did guy who's
waited around 2300 did he lost maybe
four years ago and I memorized the game
and this was a second game I played and
all the all the moves that we played
were exactly the same as in that game
that he was five years ago
and it was about at the critical the
critical condition that he didn't play
the losing move like she did in that
game and we eventually ended up wrong so
I want one the first game and I drew the
other game against the 2,300 rated
player and basically all because he
didn't he didn't analyze the games or
death game he lost and which happens
quite a lot actually watched an
interview
by garry kasparov where he said that the
most important games for you to analyze
are the games you lost and the games you
want especially the games you want but
even those you lost you have to analyze
an expansion because you made a mistake
you know you're going to will always
find an improvement I'm going to play
the Honorable you played if your games
are available online so yeah that's a
little trick I use when I have to play
against the higher rated opponent and
prove the very successful in doing in
the past so yeah that's about it thank
you for watching if you'd like you
you're welcome to check out this game
which I'm pretty sure I'm going to lose
but you never know yeah that I think
this is it can we somehow stop this yeah
we can go f6 or f5 okay
just on the web sticks here
but yeah and that I'm not a lot of
players actually analyze their games
that are deflated and do the come in
handy for you as it is mean this is just
terrible
this is terrible I can't play this I was
concentrating on what I like to say and
then I stopped concentrating on the game
I really have the time to finish this
there goes the bishop okay she doesn't
want the bishop
[Music]
[Music]
yes that's that we like thanks for
watching